the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
one of the seniors in NFC who's gotten
to Chernobyl for the second time just
returned from there two weeks ago so if
you remember on Tuesday we went through
all of the physics and intuition about
why Chernobyl happened and we left off
on what does it look like today
so James gonna tell you what does it
look like today all right so first off
I'm actually gonna go over a bit of the
reactor physics involved with the
Chernobyl accident I realize you guys
have already covered this to some extent
but I didn't plan for that so it's in my
presentation also yes also I am a little
sick so I'm probably gonna start
coughing apologies I'm not dying it's
just a cold I have heard that joke about
eight times in the last two days and I'm
so done with it but yes it's not
radiation poisoning yeah all right where
is Chernobyl ah dang it
come on no go the other way the other
way yep okay there okay so one of the
first questions I got when I said I'm
gonna go and visit Chernobyl is wait
isn't that a war zone not quite so the
Ukrainian the the war in Ukraine is
mostly in this portion over here it's
not entirely under rebel control in that
area and I say rebel and quotation marks
cuz rebel means Russian however if you
notice those arrows Russian forces are
built up all along that border so while
it's not it you know it's not an active
war zone it's certainly not a place to
be spending a large amount of time that
said
Chernobyl is north of of Kiev by about I
don't know let's see 200 250 kilometers
so it's not completely out in the sticks
right it's hopefully this gives you a
good sense of roughly where it is all
right so what is the turn oval nuclear
power plant look like it consists of 4
finished reactors there are two
unfinished reactors unit 5 and 6 that
are not shown in this image units one
and two are located at the right those
were
directed in the 1970s and early 1980s
there are all of these reactors or the
RBMK type units 1 and 2 operated with
some success I'll go into that later for
a number of years before the accident
that happened in 1986 also I have some
call-outs up here that show the some of
the incidents that I'll talk about here
a little bit later in the presentation
but this just gives you a general idea
of the layout so it's force it's two
separate buildings four units one and
two and then units three and four are in
one building all connected by this turbo
generator Hall so this is where the
generators that turn the steam from the
RBMK into power are this is one giant
well before the accident this was one
giant not separated hallway basically so
you could walk from one end to the other
theoretically all right so what is an
RBMK an RBMK is a light water-cooled
graphite moderated channel type reactor
this means that it does not have a giant
pressure vessel like you would see in a
VV ER or an equivalent american light
water reactor why does that mean
anything well building giant pressure
vessels is very difficult if any of you
have done research on manufacturing of
nuclear reactors you'll find out that
the equipment necessary to construct a
reactor Pressure Vessel it's not
actually something we even have in the
US anymore is it Korea that does it for
us now Japan that does it now in the
Soviet times it was very very difficult
for the Soviet Union to produce such
pressure vessels at any kind of
reasonable rate so the RBMK
got around this by using individual
channels that were their own pressure
vessel so to speak so the way this works
is let's just start on the cold side you
take in cold water goes here through
these things these are main circulating
pumps mcps as you'll see them referred
to later in the presentation
goes up through the bottom of the core
these are the hot
Rod's the water goes from liquid to
steam phase as its flowing through the
channels comes out the top goes to the
steam water separators steam goes to the
turbines turns the turbines makes
electricity the important thing to
remember here is that we've got a giant
graphite core the graphite is what is
doing the moderating in this
circumstance it is not the water this
allows you to run very low enriched
uranium so you could theoretically run
an RBMK on I believe it was 1.2 percent
was as low as they could go but
regardless extremely low enriched
uranium which is convenient if you don't
want to waste a lot of time enriching
uranium the problem with this is is that
you have a giant core if you recall the
scattering cross section for graphite
it's pretty small and the amount of
energy lost per collision is likewise
also fairly small so the core on this
thing is c11 yeah eleven point five
meters across the core for an equivalent
American reactor so well there's no real
equivalent to this but for let's say an
AP 1000 a reactor of equivalent
electrical output is about four meters
across so the core is huge as I already
discussed this is what the individual
pressure channels look like so cool
water comes in the bottom goes by the
fuel rods pops out the top the RBMK has
some serious design flaws so as I said
the core is huge this allows local power
anomalies to form really really easily
each if you look at the core one portion
can be kind of neutronic lis separated
from the others because neutrons just
don't make it all that far when
diffusing across the core so you can
have very very high power in one corner
and very low power in the other which is
not something that can develop in a
physically smaller core which
which has a characteristic scale
equivalent to that of the neutron beam
free path further the in core flux
monitoring on the RBMK is seriously
deficient so there a variety of Neutron
detectors that exist around the
periphery of the core but they're wholly
insufficient to catch these local power
anomalies chernobyl actually found out
the hard way on this one in 1982 unit 1
suffered a localized core melt not
really something that can happen in and
LWR or really any other type of reactor
but a couple of the fuel channels
actually experienced one of these local
power anomalies and ended up melting so
if you go into the control room of unit
1 you can see that on the fuel channel
cartogram on the wall there are two of
them that are just sharpie doubt those
are the ones that melted further it has
a positive void reactivity coefficient
what does that mean well when the water
boils in the core the density of the
water there goes down and the power of
the reactor ends up going up because the
water is primarily acting not as
moderator but as a neutron absorber this
is bad for a whole variety of reasons
and they found out quite catastrophic
Lee in 1986 exactly why further the the
system is extremely unstable at low
power so how did the 1986 accident
happen
I was part of this thing called a turbo
generator rundown test the general idea
is that if you have an off-site power
failure and your main circulating pumps
are no no longer have off-site power you
somehow need to keep water flowing
through the core such that the fuel does
not melt the problem is is that the
backup large diesel generators are just
that they're large they're diesel and
therefore they're very very slow to come
online and come up to full power the way
that you can bridge this gap is by using
the energy that you stored in the
turbines to effectively power the main
circulating pumps until the diesel
generators can come up
line when unit four was fully
constructed in 1983 and turned on for
the first time they had never actually
done this test where they did a turbo
generator rundown despite the fact that
it was required by law in the Soviet
Union that all new new power stations
should have this test performed it was
delayed until 1986 and yeah it was
delayed until 1986 is the long story
short the test procedure sorry for all
the text on this slide is basically as
follows so you would ramp the reactor
down so you would bring it from a normal
thermal output of up to about 2,400
megawatts thermal down to six or seven
hundred megawatts you'd bring the turbo
generators up to full speed so you'd
store as much energy in them as you
possibly could then cut off the steam
supply such that now you are just
extracting energy from the spinning
turbo generator this would then be used
to power the main circulating pumps each
of which took about 40 megawatts there
eight of them total I believe six could
be used for normal operation the run
down would take somewhere in the range
of 60 to 70 seconds and hopefully by
this time your diesel generators would
be turned on pumping water and
everything would be fine what happened
in the test was decidedly quite
different from that so on April 26th in
1986 they they attempted to begin this
test about six hours behind schedule
because there was a incident in another
part of the Ukraine in which a coal
power plant went offline so what
happened was the authority for the grid
in the area ordered that Chernobyl
should stay online at full power for you
know an additional six hours they began
the test by bringing power down but as a
result of running for extra for an extra
six hours they'd built up a significant
amount of xenon precursors in the core
so when they started turning the power
down the power started going down and
down and down and they were unable to
arrest its drop
what ended up happening was that the
power dropped all the way down to 30
megawatts thermal and the reactor
operators kind of panicked their
response to this instead of cancelling
the test was to pull out as many control
rods as they could get their hands on
they did so and this managed to rescue
the thermal output of the reactor and it
bumped up to around 200 megawatts
thermal at this point the reactor was in
an extremely unstable State mind you
almost all the rods that they could get
their hands on were out of the reactor
the only thing keeping reactivity at a
reasonable level was all the xenon that
was built up in the core at this point
they began the turbo generator run down
tests they shut off steam to the main
turbine or one of the turbines after it
was after it was run up to full power
and then attempted to run the main
circulating pump the main circulating
pump started drawing down the energy
from the spinning turbine and as a
result it ran slower and slower meaning
that the flow through the core was less
and less more water boiled going into
steam which increased the reactivity as
a result the power output of the core
went up it burned out more xenon and the
cycle continued they noticed a power
excursion about 40 seconds after they
began the test and at this point
recognized they were in bad territory
and hit the scram button this would jam
pretty much all of the available control
rods into the core including some
emergency extras and shut everything
down in most circumstances this would be
a fairly safe move but in the case of
the RBMK it was most certainly not RBMK
control rods have a graphite tip on them
when jammed into the core they caused a
localized power increase because the
graphite is a great moderator and it is
displacing water which is a great
absorber and as a result after they made
it a couple meters into the core the
increased pressure in the core from the
power output
which was localized around the tips the
control rods ended up shattering the
control rod control rod drive mechanisms
and instead of turning off the cycle
basically just continued power continued
to ramp up over the next couple of
seconds it eventually reached somewhere
around 10 to 20 times the maximum rated
thermal output of the system and a
massive steam explosion ended up ripping
through the facility it tossed the 2000
ton biological shield on top of the
reactor through the roof of the facility
it ejects a significant portion of the
fuel as well as the moderator in the
core and it started a massive fire
around the facility just to give you a
good sense of scale see how I've got the
virtual laser pointer that's person
right here this little guy this is the
top of the biological field
alena shield and then this is the this
is a model a cutaway model of the
Chernobyl reactor facility with the
shield and with the yeah with a flip
shield that went up through the roof and
came back down so as you can see was an
utterly massive explosion so the damage
to the reactor was you know immediately
quite catastrophic moderator blocks fuel
was spread all around the immediate area
if you look in this photo it's rather
difficult to see but at the bottom of
that column of smoke you can actually
see the bottom of the biological shield
kind of gives you a sense of the scale
of the damage to the reactor after the
explosion happened actually none of the
operators believed the reactor reached
confinement in any way they didn't
really have an immediate way of seeing
what had happened so they opened the
door and went to the main turbo
generator building to investigate the
damage they believed it was perhaps one
or two ruptured fuel channels as it
happened at I believe the Leningrad I
think it was in Leningrad power station
a few years earlier in the few seconds
that they were there they received fatal
doses and died in the hospital in May of
1986 this is a photo from control room
of reactor 4 showing a jammed
control rod drive at the six meter
position so this was probably a rod see
this is a probably a rod coming up from
the bottom and that it yeah it seven
meters would be all the way out zero
meters would be all the way in the
initial response to this despite the
fact that the reactor operators who were
not yet dead did realize that it was a
full breach of containment was the
response was to an accident that was
non-nuclear in nature so when the fire
department got a call from the authority
at Chernobyl the message that they
received was there's a fire three actor
complex as a result what they showed up
with was not equipment suitable for a
hazmat situation in any way that said
there's pretty much nothing that could
shield anyone from the extremely high
radiation field that one would encounter
around the reactor and the immediate
aftermath of the accident but
nonetheless they were extremely
vulnerable it was night when this
accident happened as I mentioned this
happened at 1:23 in the morning they
actually couldn't see the extent of the
accident and they initially believed
that it was just a fire on the roof of
the turbo generator building they
attempted to fight the fire and some of
them actually succumb to acute radiation
poisoning or acute radiation syndrome
almost immediately a number of
firefighters went up on the roof and
just didn't come back
the aftermath of the accident the
cleanup was handled by the Soviet Army
the people that were involved in this
were known as the liquidators they would
spend several minutes on the rooftop of
the turbogenerator building or up near
where the reactor was the reactor
containment building was and they would
receive a effectively a lifetime dose
which I believe was believed their limit
was 50 REM and that would be a couple of
minutes up there see this photo doesn't
show much evidence of it but I suppose
it shows a little bit of evidence of it
if you look around the bottom of the
frame you can actually see a little bit
of hazing in kind of a periodic fashion
let's see if I can get my pointer on it
here here here here and here
that's the gear that moves the film is
actually shielding the film from
radiation exposure at those points the
radiation dose rate was so high up there
that most of the pictures that were
taken just didn't turn out whatsoever
a few smarter photographers used a whole
lot of lead and were able to capture
photos like this but nonetheless the
dose rates were tremendous the reactor
structure itself was entombed in this
thing that we call the sarcophagus
people in Ukraine call it the object
shelter or the shelter object it was
constructed in starting almost
immediately after the accident basically
it can to keep radioactive graphite and
fuel fragments from leaving the reactor
structure and contaminating any more
land this is a photo from when it was
under construction basically what it
consisted of were steel and concrete
walls that were erected around around
the reactor using a variety of
technologies they at first attempted to
use robots that were almost immediately
rendered useless by the high radiation
field later on they ended up using quote
bio robots people too
move things into place as I've said
before a whole lot of people died in
this accident both immediately and after
many during the construction of the
sarcophagus actually during the initial
firefighting that our initial
firefighting measures as the the core
remained burning for a number of weeks
after the accident they attempted to put
it out with bags of sand drop from
helicopters and during that effort a
helicopter actually ended up hitting one
of the cranes that they were attempting
to use for this and falling into the
reactor and a good portion of its
remains remain entombed within the
sarcophagus from what I understand all
right
so my visit to Chernobyl why would
anyone ever want to go there
the primary focus was to learn about
radiological decontamination at the site
basically how was contamination control
managed how do workers stay safe mind
you there are 3,000 people that go to
work there every day and what are the
strengths and what are the shortcomings
of their radiological program it was
seven days total four of which were on
site other days were spent in Pripyat as
well as in some classroom training which
I've got great photos of so this is a
slide stolen directly from the
PowerPoint that I was sent on day one
but this was organized by three people
Carl Willis Eric Embry and and Ed Geist
I've known Carl for a few years now he
lives in Albuquerque New Mexico and is a
radiation safety officer at a company
that I think they do advanced energy
storage technologies I'm not exactly
sure eric is a firefighter and
specializes in radiation emergency
response and edward works at the RAND
Corporation and does nuclear history and
nuclear security research this is the
team this year so we've got let's start
here this is Lucas he does environmental
radiation monitoring that's me after
having no sleep because I did a 22-6 11
pset
before I know I look so happy to be
there
this is Nathan Nathan builds organs as
in the musical instrument
he was along because he's always been
interested in Chernobyl but didn't
really have any experience in the field
this is Stanislaus Stanislaus was our
guide from the Chernobyl authority he's
been working at the plant since 1991 and
is a fantastic resource for information
this is Edie who I believe I talked
about earlier and this is Ryan Pierce
I'm not really sure what he does this is
Harris who is a friend of Carl's and
works in believe radiation oncology and
then Danelle Hogan who's an educator
based in Phoenix Arizona who works with
the do-e by the way if you're wondering
why we're all wearing those absurd robes
it was before we were going to go in to
another room and change into basically
coveralls which are easy to
decontaminate one of the activities that
we did was real decontamination training
so that is a truck from the no Varco
worksite which by the way that is me
with the Geiger counter
I'm surveying for contamination we then
pressure washed the truck as it turns
out there's a very specific technique
one needs to use for pressure washing
when you're dealing with a contaminated
object so as to not blast contaminated
dirt up back onto the truck
this was a very interesting experience
and also one that was very entertaining
for the workers involved because they
don't actually wear that when they're
doing decontamination because their
respect for safety protocols or shall we
say a bit different so they got to see
us wear the absurd rubberducky suits
while they stood by smoking and laughing
at us
I believe you can actually see the
corner of that guy's jacket back there
and he's just wearing everyday clothes
we also went on the new safe confinement
worksite so I I haven't talked about it
earlier in this presentation but I
suppose I should have there is a object
called the new safe confinement arch
that consists of basically a giant
stainless steel structure on Rails which
is being slid over reactor four so as to
prevent the spread of any sort of
contamination from it this is known as
the new safe confinement or NSC arch
it's been under construction since 2007
and it just moved for the first time
actually while I was there so on the
12th of November it's supposed to last
for a hundred years
and hopefully in that kind of time span
they'll be able to take apart what
remains of the reactor so actually what
you see here is the corner of the
sarcophagus and then if you were to pan
over this way a little bit you'd see the
right a set of tracks for the new safe
confinement arch we also did some
classroom training admittedly the
classroom training was the most
disappointing part of this the
instructors were not particularly
interested in showing us really anything
other than YouTube videos and other
things that would just waste our time
that was that was the one part of this
trip that I did not enjoy regardless we
did get to learn a little bit about the
various hazmat get-ups that folks would
wear when working on-site as I mentioned
we also got to visit Pripyat
which I have more photos up later as
well as the reactor for control room
which is inside the sarcophagus which is
quite a treat to visit the reactor for
control room is not terribly
contaminated as a result of
decontamination efforts during the
accident the dose rate would have been
somewhere in the range of 5 to 10 ram an
hour but today it's in the range of 10
mm an hour this is the new safe
confinement arch that I've been talking
about this is actually a photo from 2015
with a clip art Statue of Liberty on it
but give you an idea of how huge it is
you know 5 meters taller than the Statue
of Liberty and it's on Rails
which is interesting it's actually too
big for wheels so it's not on Rails like
with wheels on them it's on Rails with
giant Teflon scoots this is the inside
of the turbo generator hallway remember
that long building that I showed you
that connected reactors one and two and
three and four this is right outside the
reactor 3 part of it there are I think
I'll show you these photos later there
are chunks of the turbine from reactor 4
that are down here in this area that are
quite visibly radioactive and are very
easy to detect if one swings a Geiger
counter about within Pripyat we also
visited a hospital 126 which is where
the firefighters went immediately after
the accident that is the ones that made
it off the roof this garment here we're
not exactly sure what it was because
none of us we're gonna really touch it
but we think it might have been part of
a cover it would go under one's helmet
was extremely radioactive it was
contaminated with alpha beta and gamma
which is fairly unusual alpha
contamination is fairly rare around the
Chernobyl site and was somewhere around
50 to 75 mr an hour on contact
I think I already showed you photos the
control room yep unit four that's the
cartogram so that would display various
parameters of the reactor for each fuel
channel depending on how one configured
it that's an external photo of the
sarcophagus and I think that that's it
for the PowerPoint slides I do have a
bunch of photos though that I think you
will find interesting I apologize if
it's a little disorganized this is this
was put together relatively recently
because well I just got back from
Chernobyl and then I went to a
conference and then I came back here and
tried to get work done right so these
are in chronological order roughly I'll
go through and hopefully tell you guys a
little bit about what the sites like
okay okay so this is on day one we're
driving to the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant site that blue and white bus is
pretty much what everyone uses for
transport around there all right so
we're not really supposed to be taking
photos in this area so everything is
tilted because I was taking them out the
window with a camera like that that's
the new safe confinement arch it's in
considerably better shape than it was
last year at this time they have done a
fantastic job of putting it together
it's actually almost a year ahead of
schedule
there it is again
you can see the sarcophagus with the new
support wall which is that right there
all right so this is our excursion into
Pripyat on our second day so this is the
group led by Stanislaus as you can see
there's not very much left just in
comparison to what we saw last year the
number of buildings that had been taken
apart for scrap metal illegally of
course was pretty huge in I don't know
five or ten years it's gonna be very
difficult to see much of Pripyat at all
frankly so this is a standard apartment
block in Pripyat as you can see a lot of
broken windows a lot of bricks have
fallen off these things are pretty
dangerous a lot of tourists do go into
them if one decides to do a tourist
expedition to Chernobyl which I don't
particularly recommend don't go in the
apartment blocks this is on the way to
one of the schools
this is Lukas who has more detectors
than anyone I've ever met it was wearing
seven at the time so I had to take a
photo of him this is Aris imitating some
of the graffiti which unfortunately has
popped up all over the place
Pripyat itself is really decaying
quickly as I've said there's a huge
problem with looting in addition there's
a huge problem with graffiti and
vandalism it's it's really depressing
honestly to go there and see how much
has changed just in a year so despite my
earlier warning we did go in an
apartment block this is just a
measurement showing that the background
up there actually is not terribly high
that's Aris not particularly safety
conscious at times
this gives you a good idea of how far
away prep yacht is from the reactor that
is not very far about two kilometers as
you can see the new safe confinement
arch to the top left of the detector
background there is about and in this
particular apartment block at this
particular time was about four to five
times what you would see in downtown
Cambridge there are wild animals in prep
yacht and the rest of the exclusion zone
this is a huge problem so despite the
fact that the cats are very cute and the
puppies are very cute they also have
rabies it's not all of them but a very
large number of them in 2009 five
workers were injured by I kid you not a
rabid wolf there's a YouTube video of
this that you can look up on your own
time if you so wish this is because
Ukraine doesn't have a lot of money so
they have not been able to continue with
their vaccination program they actually
use baits that have a rabies vaccine in
them - normally suppress rabies and wild
animal populations but Ukraine doesn't
have any money they killed the program
about five years ago and as a result
there's a huge huge problem with
especially rabid foxes because everyone
thinks foxes are cute especially
tourists and foxes when they get rabies
some of them go through a stage in which
they appear to be very friendly as far
as I know no one has gotten rabies from
a rabid animal at Renault at Chernobyl
but it's certainly a possibility so
stanislaus was being a very bad example
by feeding one of the wild cats so
that's why I took a picture of it this
is one of the many memorials that you'll
find in downtown LA voltage we stayed in
the city that was built effectively as a
replacement for Pripyat it's actually a
fantastic town I really enjoy Slava
touch and as one might expect there are
memorials everywhere because the entire
population is basically the folks that
were removed from the the town of
Pripyat this is a train we would take
every day so abuta CH is
separated from Pripyat by a little
isthmus of Belarus that drops down so
that's bad because you can't get a visa
to Belarus it's not really a thing you
can do as an American I mean you can
apply for one you'll just never hear
back Belarus is Europe's last
dictatorship and it's not some place one
wants to go for any reason so when we
would get on this train the doors would
shut we would go through Belarus and we
would all pray that it didn't break down
because then we would have to spend some
time in a Belarusian prison
but yeah this is the train yard bright
and early the various zones on the
reactor site for cleanliness so to speak
radiological cleanliness are separated
by these benches effectively that you
have to step over so that it reminds you
that hey this is the clean area you need
to be wearing boot covers and you know
at least these governments in order to
go here sideways for some reason this is
part of the alright I don't know why
these are all sideways but regardless
you get the picture if you notice on the
top of the screen which should be the
left of the screen let's see if I can
rotate it that's a giant puddle of water
this place is falling apart despite the
fact that they have money from the
European Bank on reconstruction and
development for the new safe confinement
arch the Chernobyl site itself does not
have a lot of money and as a result
things are falling apart and the amount
of contamination that is getting into
places where it very much shouldn't be
like this quote clean area is fairly
high that puddle of water was pretty
toasty something like 5 to 8 mr an hour
on contact that's that's generally quite
bad as I said water is coming in
everywhere and in this case they were
using leg covers to catch the water
another one of the hallways that had
water leaked into it and therefore all
the lights are out the footwear which we
were issued which breaks after walking
about a kilometer which is not
particularly encouraging if one wants to
take their boots back again walking down
the hallway if you notice this gold
corrugated material that you see on the
sides it's aluminum that is anodized and
it's placed there because it covers up
all of the sheets of lead that were
affixed to the wall what happened is in
the aftermath of the accident the entire
facility was just hopelessly
contaminated and you can scrub all you
want but ultimately it's very difficult
to get radioactive contamination off of
things so what they ended up doing was
getting it down to a somewhat acceptable
level and then fastening sheets of lead
over it and then fashion and fastening
this stuff over the top of that this is
unit twos control room so this is what a
fully fleshed-out control room looks
like unit c ؈ unit two was shut down in
2000 the reactors actually continued
operating after the 1986 Chernobyl
accident because Ukraine was in such
desperate need of power as a result the
fuel is still fairly hot it's producing
a reasonable amount of decay heat and
there is a crew that sits in the control
room at all times monitoring it that's
Nathan this is actually I took a picture
of this because it's a very good diagram
of the Chernobyl reactor that's
simplified it
it shows the core and the relative
locations of these steam water
separators okay as I said there's a team
that stays in there so there are people
that work on site and work in the
reactor control rooms which I have to
imagine has to be a bit of a surreal job
this is inside the main inside the turbo
generator all those chunks that you see
see here are from the turbo generator of
reactor 4 so they're quite contaminated
and quite easy to detect actually
there's a good story behind this so we
were trying to figure out exactly what
the what was making the dose rate so
high in the area when we were up there
so we got a group of us to stand in a
circle - one person so there's a gap we
got a person in the center with a
central scintillator and we all kind of
rotate it around until we found in which
direction the center later reading was
high enough who basically made like a 2
pie meat shield it worked fairly well it
thoroughly baffled all of the guides
that were with us they're like what are
you doing
linking arms and spinning around
regardless that is a good way to find
sources if you're in a pinch this is
looking the other direction from that
that same vantage point is in the last
photo behind those walls with the little
radiation signs on them are chunks of
the ventilation stack which is fairly
iconic they've been fairly well
decontaminated at that fence area the
dose rate or more accurately exposure
rate was 10 mr an hour and yeah that's
another close-up photo of it and I
managed to sneak my phone over the top
of it and get a good shot unfortunately
none of the pieces are uncovered I would
really have liked to see the orange and
white of the ventilation stack but I did
not again same shot a slightly different
shot of the turbogenerator hallway
looking in the unit 1 2 Direction more
detritus
oh here's a slightly better close up of
those components one of the interesting
things I found out about the facility is
a way that access is controlled so
instead of having like an RFID card or
something like that
they've got cameras and operators so
what you see here is a camera so
stanislaus would scan a badge that would
automatically call someone who is an
operator Stanislaus would say hey I'm at
this door I want to go into this
location will you let me in and then
they would look at the camera
determined that yes that is Stanislaus
he does want to go into this area and
then they would approve it and let him
through walking through the corridors of
the sarcophagus can actually see up here
those lead sheets I was talking about
I don't know how thick they are on there
or how close they are to falling off for
that matter but I'm sure several
thousand pounds of lead is right there
alone these are main circulating pumps
one half of the main circulating pumps
for reactor two and each one of these
things takes something around Luke
something around 40 megawatts to
actually operate these were these are
aligned differently and are of a
different type and the ones used in
reactor four because reactors wanted to
were of an earlier design ironically
enough reactors 1 & 2 actually don't
have all of the safety measures that
reactor 4 does which is a bit terrifying
to think of get more photos right as I
said Dawg problem at Chernobyl this is
right outside the entrance to a clean
facility and occasionally these dogs
would wander in unfortunately dogs are
large furry piles of easily airborne
contamination so they would walk in you
know people would go to shoo them out
they would shake their coats or whatever
and then you know clean-up on aisle 3
because now there's contamination
everywhere
more sad looking puppies new safe
confinement yet again to give you an
idea of scale let's play find the
workers zoom in
those are workers right there you guys
see them yeah they're really really
small next to this facility yeah I think
I've got a slightly better shot here
that's that's a guy right there
there's also another dude right here
yeah this place is or this structure is
absolutely enormous it's really hard to
wrap your head around exactly how large
it is so this is in an area called the
local zone so it's the immediate several
hundred meters surrounding the reactor
as you can see the hazmat equipment that
we're wearing there is significantly
different from what we would wear inside
the reactor or inside the sarcophagus
mostly because the threat from dust this
area is pretty huge as you can see we're
walking on fill it's actually meters and
meters of fill because the ground was so
contaminated that they scraped it away
put fill in there put fill on top of
that because just the residual
contamination was enough to make it
hazardous to use as a worksite though
they're not shown in this image or I
believe any images here there are there
are little concrete and lead structures
that the workers take breaks behind
because you have a dose limit that is
enforced while you're working there and
if you're gonna take a smoke break as a
huge fraction of the population of
Ukraine smokes or you know you're gonna
take a break of another sort they don't
want you racking up dose during that
time so you basically hide in a little
concrete Shack for a while with a few
inches of lead between you and the
reactor yet another shot inside the
sarcophagus
edie explaining something about which I
know
as you can see this place is not exactly
in the best condition on the inside and
one thing that did concern me a lot was
the amount of dust that was very very
easy to kick up in the area this is
inside control room of reactor 4 selfie
which I didn't mean to have in this
album control room for hasn't changed a
whole lot since last year but there is a
dividing wall that actually separates
reactors 3 & 4 that's being put together
and it cuts right through the edge of
the fourth control room and for a while
he actually didn't know whether or not
we were gonna be able to visit it at all
because of ongoing construction I'm very
glad that we were able to most of the
instruments have been removed it's
unclear as to why we've been told that
some of it was because of contamination
but the pattern doesn't really make
sense this is the reactor control room
cartogram excuse me reactor core
cartogram which as I said was lit and
could display various parameters
regarding the various fuel channels
there's only two control rod indicator
well yeah they're really only these
control rod indicators left and we
believe that actually some of these
might not be original someone might have
stolen the real one and put another one
back I don't have any evidence to
support it but I suspect that there's
significant looting that happens in here
this is a rather entertaining photo that
means smoking area that's in the control
room you shouldn't be smoking you
shouldn't take your mask off for any
reason it's a high gamma radiation
warning sign it was in fact not that
high of the dose rate somewhere in the
range of 30 mr an hour we also explored
a little bit outside of the more formal
part of the reactor premises namely we
went to this place called Berea Kafka -
which is a burial facility for waste
from the reactor not waste as in nuclear
waste but waste is in chunks of metal
and other things that are contaminated
and therefore removed when the new safe
confinement Arch was being built or when
let's say they were building the
separation wall between reactors 3 & 4
and there were some incredibly hot spots
so right I think I have some more photos
later but just under that little
triangle the dose rate was a hundred and
fifty mr an hour so 0.15 REM an hour
it's extremely high and that was just in
a field basically not controlled not
patrolled no warning signs getting
dressed up lots of fun that was the
truck we were sent to decontaminate
honestly wasn't particularly
contaminated in the first place they
weren't going to give us real fun things
to play with it's all of us and then as
you notice the real workers here are not
wearing even a fraction of what we are
or decontamination yeah see barely
anything
these are chunks of metal that have come
out of the reactor we're not exactly
sure what part what parts they are no
one was really able to answer our
questions about them but they were also
rather contaminated somewhere in the
range of 50 to 75 mr an hour on contact
in some spots more photos of Chernobyl
or of Chernobyl from Pripyat yes
yes only the cold I picked up on the way
back the total dose that I received on
this entire expedition - that flights
there and back was 0.6 millisievert so
effectively nothing I've well all of the
high radiation areas that we were in we
were encouraged to walk quickly
it's basically what it comes down to
that the time portion of time distance
and shielding was emphasized further
questions yeah
no ideological control in Ukraine is a
totally different game than it is in the
u.s. there are the same types of
controls that exist in the u.s. just
don't exist
at that site there are four areas that
are immediately dangerous to your health
you know 10 R at an hour something like
that from what I understand that there
are there are locked doors that prevent
one from accessing those accidentally
and there are warning signs in a variety
of locations but I don't think that
there is a the same standardization of
you know 5mr an hours a radiation area
etc etc yeah further no you won't be
able to see the sarcophagus itself
because it will be contained within the
new safe confinement arch pretty much
now it's 75 right let's see last I
checked the new safe confinement arch
with a 75% of the way over the reactor
itself regular tourist visits to Pripyat
will continue to happen this program
that I went on is something very special
Carl Eadie and Eric have done this type
of thing once before that was the trip I
went on last year and they intend on
doing it once a year as long as they can
but that's pretty much your only
opportunity to get that kind of access
to the reactor it takes a lot of work
anyone else
eat something that's actually gone here
Chernobyl in the state yeah
no um there's a there's a rather
haunting location though the Kadhim
truck memorial so when the accident
happened there was one guy who was
depending on how you look at it either
lucky or unlucky and that he wasn't
killed by radiation poisoning he was
killed by being flattened in the
explosion and his remains are within the
reactor and within the sarcophagus never
really recovered him better than dying
of radiation poisoning but nonetheless
you know not a fantastic way to go the
memorial that is within the sarcophagus
is pretty interesting to visit and you
know rather somber makes you reflect a
little bit on the enormous human toll
that the accident had
you